the Joe Rogan experience now what year
did you come over here how old were you
17 17 what was this shift like going
from Singapore to the United States you
live in New York then no no your your
hometown right yeah yeah I lived in
Boston for 10 years really enjoyed it
actually
ken Cole was [ __ ] it no I like it I
don't know I'm a skier sorry I really
liked it but there was huge culture
shock in a way I knew was signing up for
I I chose a man like it's actually
easier for a Singaporean to
plug-and-play into any of the
Commonwealth countries because it was a
former British colony so all your
credits would just transfer kind of more
easily to university in England for
example or Australia but I chose America
precisely for the first amendment real
it was very it was a very strong
motivating factor for me and also just
the the culture of like we said
celebrating weird people yes because I
was weird so I wanted to be in a place
where I thought I would be what made you
weird so a Singapore is pretty
conformist in terms of you talk about
monocultures there there is a conformist
right like there is the right schools
you go to the right paths you take very
entrenched and I really rebelled against
that like you know Singapore Chu ain't
got my boundary yeah I have a chewing
gum because it was banned in Singapore
it's one of those things it's just like
stuck in my mind I can I grown up here I
probably wouldn't be chewing this right
now it wouldn't just wouldn't matter but
when when somebody says I can't like
like do not touch wet paint like yeah
this has always been a part of your
personality from the time you were young
yes was this nature or nurture don't
know I I don't know I really but so when
you came to America when you're 17 said
yeah was that like yes it was but it was
also there were a lot of culture shocks
that I had to adapt to you know for
starters it definitely felt like a bit
of a
step back for me in terms of how in
terms of comfort of living like standard
living the United States is kind of a
third world country compared to
Singapore really yeah one Boston though
when I landed in Logan and we were
taking that drive to you know like at
the time I was gonna be living in
Cambridge we win my undies like highways
I'm like it's rusting this was kind of
like just like me before the Big Dig was
done and the infrastructure was kind of
broken the potholes your health care
what the hell is up with that so with a
step back in material comforts for me
and in Singapore you know if you grew up
even middle-class like the 50th
percentile family can afford a domestic
helper so many Singaporeans in fact
ninety percent of all the kids I know
growing up all grew up with maids
picking up after them doing their
laundry everything so Singapore is no
minimum wage no minimum wage and so if
you measure employment in that country
it's it's in some economic measurements
the way they do it it's almost like it's
over employed don't have an unemployment
problem everybody has a job pretty much
no minimum wage but what what how do
people take be taking advantage how are
people taking advantage because of that
well that's why we just are on average
low and that in Singapore they're not
that high the United States practices
what you call efficiency wages which is
you know they they kind of pay people a
little bit more to to extract a better
performance right incentives matter
right in Singapore that's not the case
but in Singapore the streets are taking
care of better bridges oh the
destruction you know I I tweet a maybe
like last week seeing something like
especially now we're in like political
debate season I'm so tired of this whole
left-right argument like small
government no big government
government's a problem got a solution
it's it's about effective government and
I think that's something that the the
same poor government had really
perfected its its effective governance
it's not about the size we're gonna I
don't care whether this is a policy that
came from the right or the left it's
what works people respond to incentives
right and if you want to encourage a
certain kind of behavior you there's
carrots and sticks to basically
encourage that behavior and so it's
there there are things that the
government would do in a way that just
would never fly here where you you know
we treasure civil liberties too much in
a way which I personally came here for
that reason but I'll give you a good
example social cohesion is engineered in
Singapore so there's it's a very very
multicultural multi-ethnic society you
have Malay Muslims Indians Hindus
Chinese who are Buddhists Christians and
you know Caucasians all living in an
island city-state that's about five
million in terms of population and how
the government manages this
multicultural project is that eighty
percent of people actually live in
public housing that's very high it's
like a socialist thing right public
housing the government builds for you
and each block has to mimic the racial
demographics of the whole country so you
don't have ghettos right so imagine like
a housing state that basically mirrors
like okay is the total makeup of the
country if 60% Chinese 20% Malay Muslims
it has to follow so you can't have
basically an area like Birmingham in the
UK where all the Muslim immigrants or or
you know something like Durban Michigan
or Minnesota with all the Somali
immigrants you are forced to integrate
it's a it's a way to force people to
integrate and have you know neighbors
that are just not not your own kind and
that's how they've created this like
national identity that's very strong
[Applause]